فريق البحث القادس السعودي من ضمن
المساعدات المتنوعه التي يوجه بها مولاي
خادم الحرمين الشريفين ويسموه سيدي ولي
العهد حيث تنوعت المساعدات الى مواد
غذائيه وطبيه اضافه الى تحرك الوصول فريق
القائد السعودي وهو فريق دولي في مجال
اعمال البحث والانقاذ ويضم تخصصات متنوعه
وطبيه وهندسية بالاضافه الى تجهيزات
الفنيه اللازمه لاعمال البحث والانقاذ وصل
يوم امس علامات لطائرتين اليوم موجودين في
منطقه الابراهيملي في احد الابنيه
المنهاره حيث باشر فريق البحث والانقاذ
السعودي اعماله في البحث
منذ صباح اليوم ولا زالت اعمال البحث
مستمره
موقع اخر ممكن ان يبدا فرق البحث عن
القائد السعودي ايضا التعامل معه قريب من
الموقع الاول جهود كبيره ومستمره الحقيقه
يقوم بها فريق البحث القاضي السعودي من
ضمن المنظومه عمل المرك مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه
والمساعده بالاضافه الى ايضا طواقم من
الهلال الاحمر
والمتطوعين الحقيقه الكل يعمل في منظومه
انسانيه واحده كم عدد يعني افراد هذا
الفريق الذي وصل الى هذه المناطق عقيد
محمد
فريق البحث القادم السعودي يتجاوز المئه
فرد بين ضابط وفرد وتخصصات طبيه وهندسيه
وايضا فنيين متخصصين في الاعمال الدقيقه
بالاضافه الى اليات ومعدات وتجهيزات دوليه
في مجال البحث والانقاذ ممتاز اين سيتركز
عمل يعني هؤلاء
يعني هذا الفريق اولا وكذلك المتطوعين
الذين وصلوا معهم بالتاكيد هناك تنسيق مع
منظمه دولي بحث التي يتم توزيع المواقع
بين فرق الانقاذ التي تباشر لكي يتم توزيع
الجهود حاليا موجودين في منطقه
الابراهيملي في ابراج البولان
للعمل فيها منذ صباح اليوم ايضا هناك برج
مجاور ايضا سيتم مباشره من قبل الفريق
الانقاذ بالتنسيق مع منظمه الدوليه للبحث
والانقاذ